[Aplausos]
les voy a contar una historia
y vamos en camino al aeropuerto mi mamá
y yo porque tenía que viajar ese fin de
semana para impartir un taller ese día
me había levantado más temprano de lo
normal porque tenía que terminar y
mallet a tiempo
y sumado a eso me había desvelado toda
la semana para terminar mi experiencia
que ya se imaginarán mi cara a las 5 en
la mañana lo único que quería era dormir
de pronto se le ocurre a mi mamá
contarme
oier hija fíjate que anoche me quedé
viendo el vídeo de la trayectoria de
este músico que acaba de fallecer
y me empiezo a contar
que desde niño este músico había sido
muy cambiado pero como que no le había
ido muy bien en sus trabajos hasta que
finalmente se acomodó en uno
en esta etapa le empezó a llamar la
atención la música en especial tocar el
acordeón
así que de forma autodidacta aprende a
tocar
así que tenía la paz ese trabajo
y el hobby que hacían sus tablas libres
un día decidió pronunciar su trabajo por
perseguir de lleno lo que más le
apasionaba por supuesto eso no le
pareció a su mamá a él no le importó y
continuar pasaron los años y empezó a
generar más ingresos de lo que era nada
en su antiguo trabajo
ah y su mamá entendió
pero llegar ahí no fue fácil si pasó por
muchos obstáculos comentarios negativos
incluso de personas cercanas a él
pero él no decisión llegar al éxito él
tomó más de 30 años y en eso me dice mi
mamá
así que hija nunca dejes de hacer lo que
más te apasiona de eso se trata tu
plástica no
en ese instante me cayó el 20 de lo que
me estaba contando y me dije jim y tu
mamá tiene toda la razón así que gracias
a más
les platico esto porque no todo es miel
sobre ojuelas he pasado por momentos y
experiencias en mi vida que me han
encaminado a lo que hago hoy en día me
siento afortunada de tener en mi trabajo
varias de mis pasiones moda fotografía
redes sociales diseño y la mezcla de
todos estos fue lo que me llevó a crear
una agencia creativa donde los pusiera a
la práctica
cuando tienes 17 años decidir a qué te
quieres dedicar toda tu vida suele ser
una decisión muy agobiante a poco no
a poco lado
muchos de nosotros nos dejamos
influenciar por lo que un conocido o por
lo que un amigo o incluso por nuestros
padres para decidir qué estudiar y no
nos basamos por lo que en realidad nos
gusta o nos apasiona hacer
preguntas como y ya sabes que vas a
estudiar
investigaste bien de que vas a vivir
en dónde vas a trabajar ahí no estudies
eso porque te vas a morir de hambre
o 'la prima un amigo es tuyo eso le va
súper bien
a poco no es intimidante esa decisión
le ponemos tanto peso estas preguntas
que avanzamos nuestra decisión en eso y
saben qué pasa después
ocurren dos cosas
una
estudia es algo que termine por encantar
te y créeme que si tu eres uno de esos
eres una persona muy afortunada
o dos
que estoy es algo y que de verdad digas
esto no es lo mío
y por más que trates y trates no
encuentras ese amor no lo encuentras esa
pasión que haces
vuelves a iniciar
repites el camino inicios otra carrera
haces a un lado lo que estudiaste porque
no te gustó el resultado
si estás pasando por este caso
te voy a dar una escuela
no pasa nada no pasa nada cuántos casos
tenemos hoy en día de personas que
iniciaron su carrera su carrera y
terminaron dedicándose a algo totalmente
distinto
alguien que estudió arquitectura y
terminó diseñando calzado deportivo o
alguien que inició su carrera en
medicina y terminó diseñando el trajes
de baño
y así les podría nombrar muchísimos
casos
y les digo algo todos estos mensajes que
ven son de personas que pasaron por lo
mismo
parece como si estudiar algo en
particular fuera la única solución a
nuestra vida y no tiene por qué ser así
cuando te estás conociendo tienes que
pasar por muchas experiencias y esas
experiencias te van a dar las
herramientas para descubrir qué es lo
que te gusta qué es lo que te apasiona
así que te digo no pasa nada
cuando me preguntan jim y como le puedo
hacer para descubrir aquello como le
puedo hacer para descubrir esa pasión
como le puedo hacer
no puedes
unir los puntos mirando hacia delante
sólo puedes unirlos mirando hacia atrás
entonces tienes que confiar que en algún
momento los puntos se unirán
esta frase que les comparto es una de
mis favoritas porque hace mucho sentido
con lo que les estoy diciendo cómo
podemos descubrirlo
avanzando no quedarnos estáticos porque
la única forma de saber qué es lo que
estamos haciendo es avanzando cuando
avanzamos todo empieza a cobrar sentido
nuestras experiencias se vuelven más
claras si no veamos iniciado en el punto
a hamás hubiéramos llegado al punto ver
recuerdo mi primer semestre arquitectura
para ser honesta si estaba un poco
perdida con decirles que
se me pegaron los dedos y uno de mis
primeros ejercicios y obviamente obvio
una amiga me tuvo que ayudar a
despegarlos y se estuvo burlando de mí
por mucho tiempo
me la pasaba bien
al disfrutar algunas clases pero había
algo dentro de mí que me decía aquí
nuestro lugar
empecé a distraerme con otras
actividades y así fue como descubrí los
blogs de moda
eso para mí fue un nuevo despertar
abrí mi propio blog y empezó a compartir
mi forma mi forma de vestir
luego ese blog me llevó a apasionarme
por algo más que fue la fotografía
quería tomar las mejores fotos para este
blog y como aprendí así solita así
andaba por la vida con mi cámara
tomándole fotos a todo
y me dije si llamo a esto es como hobby
porque no lo hago de forma oficial
así fue como apliqué para ser fotógrafo
del periódico universitario
tristemente no había un puesto para mí y
en su lugar me dieron uno en diseño
editorial y dije pues bajo
no tenía ni idea de cómo se usaban los
programas pero dije qué tan difícil
puede ser así que empecé diseñando de lo
más básico y poco a poco fui notando que
el lenguaje de los diseñadores gráficos
era muy similar a lo que veíamos en
arquitectura
y dije wow esto me encanta
me gradué
y ya estaban listas
enfrentarme al mundo laboral como toda
la arquitecta prepare mi portafolio con
mis mejores proyectos y mande un chorro
de correos a todos los despachos de
arquitectura
y en una entrevista en particular
me dijeron
oye y no te gustaría hacer eso que haces
para tu blog con nosotros
y yo me quedé es de verdad que me estás
preguntando esto
claramente yo estaba con toda la
disposición de ser arquitecta dudaba si
eso ese trabajo era para mí
pero dije que puedes perder nada al
contrario que vas a ganar
y acepta
sin darme cuenta los puntos se estaban
uniendo
esa experiencia para mí fue de las más
enriquecedoras porque me ayudó a
despertar en lo que era buena tomé de la
foto de la moda del diseño lo que más me
llenaba y los convertí mis elementos de
trabajo para ayudar a otras marcas a
posicionarse mejor en los medios
digitales
así que volviendo a la pregunta
como le puedo hacer
como descubrir aquello que te apasiona
no es una tarea fácil
es un proceso que te puede llevar años
pero te digo cómo empezar
si la persona más curiosa del mundo
al explorar exporta situaciones que te
ayuden a conocerte no esperes que algo
te guste solamente porque sí sino porque
ya lo experimentaste
y si no sabes cómo
pregúntate
que me llaman la atención
que me gustaría seguir aprendiendo
que quiere explorar
actualmente tenemos al alcance muchas
herramientas que nos permiten aprender
por internet puedo aprender a cocinar a
tocar guitarra o incluso a programar
el cielo es el límite
dile sí a tus hobbies
todos estas todas estas personas
empezaron diciéndole
y algo que les gustaba algo que hacían
en sus ratos libres
algo que les llamaba la atención
y no porque tengas muchísimos hobbies te
sientas comprometido en escoger
solamente uno
incluye unos en tu vida dejarlas que
fluyan algo para salir de eso
siempre se fiel a ti mismo
en el camino
si te vas a topar con muchos comentarios
muchos obstáculos que te van a hacer
dudar de lo que estás haciendo
a mí me pasaba que me decían gini porque
pierdes tanto tiempo en tu blog enfócate
en tu carrera
y de verdad
dude si lo que estaba haciendo vale la
pena
pero te digo algo
nunca dejes algo que te gusta que te
hace feliz por complacer a alguien más
nunca
habrá gente que no lo entienda
incluso tus hasta tus papás
pero tenga en cuenta que si te lo tomas
en serio
lo vas a lograr
no va a ser fácil
vas a estar cansado si vas a seguir
dudando de ti en muchas ocasiones
pero aguanta
las cosas que valen la pena no suceden
de un día para otro
en ese camino vas a necesitar mucha
perseverancia
crecimiento personal y sobre todo estar
abierto a experiencias que te van a
ayudar a aprender
siempre es momento de tomar acción
no hay reglas no hay edad de verdad no
hay fecha para esto
si en algún momento de tu vida ha
sentido que no te identificas con la
carrera que escogiste
no pasa nada
recuerda que tú no es eso
eres la suma de todo lo que te apasiona
gracias
[Aplausos]